[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute vier
genial und einfache dressing-rezepte ich
finde gerade bei warmem Wetter aber auch
bei kaltem eigentlich immer braucht man
Rezept Alternativen zu Dressings und so
dass man halt nicht immer das gleiche
macht ich starte jetzt direkt mit dem
Classic Dressing aber wirklich total
klassisch einfach aber auch sehr sehr
lecker dafür starten wir mit einer Base
aus Olivenöl da bitte gutes
kaltgepresstes Olivenöl verwenden nativ
extra und da macht halt wirklich aus
dass der Grund Geschmack einfach schon
lecker ist ne so und ähm ich mache noch
ein bisschen mehr rein ich mache das
immer nach Gefühl aber für euch schreibe
ich die ganz genau Mengenangaben hier
unten in die Videobeschreibung dann
könnt ihr euch das einfach aufklappen
screenshotten und einkaufen gehen wobei
die meisten Zutaten müsste der
eigentlich zu Hause haben so ein
Spritzer Zitronensaft kommt jetzt noch
rein nicht zu viel sonst zu sauer
ja das reicht mir schon dann für die
Würze Salz und Pfeffer mehr braucht es
nicht bei diesem Dressing
so ein bisschen Säure kommt noch durch
Apfelessig
wir haben ja schon die Zitrone drin
daher hier auch nur ein bisschen reintun
gerade so ein paar Tropfen und ganz zum
Schluss kommt Senf mit rein und das war
es schon das ganze verrührt ihr dann und
dann ist unser klassisches Dressing auch
schon fertig ich bin kein senfan aber
trotzdem macht das was mit dem Geschmack
also Senf pur würde ich niemals essen
aber in dem Dressing tut es wirklich was
es soll und schmeckt sehr lecker
[Musik]
wichtigste Zutat vergessen und zwar die
Knoblauchzehe ich brauche dich das gar
nicht schälen ich kann das auch so das
wissen die wenigstens tatsächlich ihr
könnt das einfach so in unsere
Knoblauchpresse reingeben und die Schale
fängt sie dann automatisch aus also wenn
ein Date hat würde ich jetzt obwohl
steht dazu ganz ehrlich ich finde nicht
dass man sich verstecken muss so
Knoblauch gehört auf jeden Fall mit rein
so und jetzt ist das Dressing fertig und
wir gehen über zu Dressing Nummer zwei
so Dressing Nummer 2 ist French Dressing
auf Basis von Joghurt ich nehme gerne
3,5%igen ich finde der 1,5 prozentige
ist ein bisschen zu flüssig der 10
prozentige ist mir dann allerdings
wieder zu fettig also ihr könnt aber
eigentlich nehmen was ihr möchtet oder
was hier gerade da habt da kommt jetzt
rein Tomatenmark und auch wieder sind
wie gesagt ich bin ein Fan aber im
Dressing tut er schon Wasser soll also
habe ich eigentlich nur Senf immer da
für meine Salatdressings so da kommen
jetzt noch Salz und Zucker rein ja
richtig gehört zucker macht einfach was
mit dem Geschmack macht den Geschmack
rund der hat das bestimmt schon mal
gehört der herzhaften Gerichten immer
ein bisschen Zucker rein und bei süßen
Rezepten immer ein bisschen Salz ich
habe jetzt noch tiefkühlkräuter und zwar
habe ich hier dill und Petersilie ihr
könnt aber auch andere Kräuter nehmen
das war voll entspannt je nachdem was
ihr da habt könnt ihr das ganz einfach
austauschen und jetzt fehlt nur noch ein
bisschen frischer Pfeffer und ein Schuss
Essig und dann verrührt ihr das und dann
ist das Dressing auch schon fertig
[Musik]
so Rezept Nummer drei da gibt es etwas
türkisches und zwar mit Granatapfelsirup
ich glaube das kennen auch die meisten
aus dem türkischen Restaurants oder
generell Türken unter sich aber auch in
der generellen orientalischen Küche in
der arabischen also es ist total weit
verbreitet hier nehme ich einfach nur
Olivenöl also gutes Olivenöl habe ich
Granatapfelsirup das ist einfach nur
Granatapfelsirup ohne irgendwelche
Zuckerzusätze etc und da gibt's echt
Unterschiede auf dem Markt ich verlinke
euch meins mal in die Infobox und da
kommt jetzt nur noch Salz rein und
dadurch dass es ein säuerliches Dressing
also geschmacklich für alle die in Salat
säuerlich mögen perfekt und da könnt ihr
dann noch zu macht drauf geben zu Markus
essigbaumgewürzt hat man ja schon vom
Namen Essig ist ja auch immer ein
bisschen säuerlicher eigentlich macht
ihr noch gerne einfach auch meinen Salat
noch mal so als grünen Abschluss aber
wenn ihr eure Dressing vorbereitet könnt
ihr das da schon direkt mit reingeben so
dann verrühre ich das und so könnt ihr
alle Dressings die ich euch heute zeige
auch tagelang im Kühlschrank aufbewahren
und dann eben immer rausholen auf euer
salädchen machen und genießen
Dressing Nummer 4 wir machen einen Honig
Kräuterdressing dafür nehmen wir uns
natürlich Honig
jetzt kommt auch wieder der Senf zum
Einsatz den würde ich jetzt auch nicht
weglassen weil gerade der Macht mit dem
Honig eben dass das total stimmig ist
wie gesagt man schmeckt die nicht raus
so lustig bei jedem Rezept hier bin ich
den Senf am besten und trotzdem sage ich
der passt aber irgendwie immer dazu so
da kommt jetzt noch Salz mit rein und
Pfeffer
so und da dürften jetzt auch zwei
Zutaten wiederum nicht fehlen und zwar
wieder gutes Olivenöl und ein Schuss
Essig noch mal für die feine Säure und
anschließend könnt ihr Kräuter nehmen
alle die ihr mögt ich schreibe euch das
was ich nutze auf jeden Fall wieder in
die Infobox damit ihr falls ihr möchtet
das ganz genau nachmachen könnt und dann
wird alles verrührt und auch dieses
Dressing ist vor allem jetzt eben durch
den Essig total lange halt beim
Kühlschrank also ihr könnt ihn wirklich
bis zu 5 Tage im Kühlschrank aufbewahren
und dann immer rausholen wenn ihr euch
gerade einen Salat macht und fast hätte
ich schon wieder mein Knoblauch
vergessen der kommt jetzt auch noch mit
rein
und dann haben wir es aber der Knoblauch
darf in meinen Augen ja auch nicht
fehlen wenn ihr sagt okay muss jetzt
nicht sein ihr könntet auch auf den
Knoblauch verzichten aber ich finde der
macht den Geschmack komplett rund und
das ist eins meiner lieblingsdressings
[Musik]
ja das war es von meinen vier Dressings
ich gönne mir jetzt diesen Salat und mal
gucken was ich mir noch so zum
Mittagessen zaubere und ansonsten
wünsche ich euch viel Spaß beim
ausprobieren macht unbedingt nach und
schreibt mir dann gerne in die
Kommentare welches Dressing ihr am
besten fandet und ihr könnt noch sehr
sehr gerne Kommentare im reinschreiben
und Vorschläge welche Top Vier Rezepte
als nächstes kommen sollen z.B Top 4
Marinaden hätte ich noch auf Lager oder
auch in die süße Richtung Top Vier
tortencremes also schreibt mir das sehr
gerne ich gönne mir jetzt noch den Salat
und sage bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]